as you know Donald Trump starting to
pick the key people in his
administration cabinet
he's already announced the Republican
National Committee Chairman Reince
Priebus will be his chief of staff
that's a big reveal and he appointed as
a chief strategist and senior advisor
the head of Breitbart News Steve Bannon
that's another appointment
now Bannon yeah okay Bannon is a bands a
pretty controversial and unusual choice
so naturally a lot of rumors are flying
about who's going to be appointed to
some of the other administration
postings well this is incredible
we managed to get ahold of some of
trumps other picks for example this is a
big story let's pretend it's true
Trump's Secretary of Defense is gonna be
Steven Seagal this is a big reveal
[Applause]
secondary from Secretary of State will
be Jeff Dunham's puppet Walter
the director of the CIA will be the spy
kids they're going to run things
sorry so now head of the FDA will be the
weird ripped old guy from online ads
Secretary of the Interior will be Pepe
the Frog we're all upset
Trump's press secretary says our
Flickerman from The Hunger Games
some said speechwriters going to be
Groot he's going to be handling this
director of Homeland Security will be
the eyeball monster from Pan's Labyrinth
and finally the Secretary of Education
will be this dog with glasses and
actually
[Applause]
you